la mémoire ne joue parfois des tours
on choisit de se rappeler ce qu'on veut
se rappeler
[Applaudissements]
et on oublie ce qu'on a besoin d'oublier
je vois pas comment je pourrais vous
raconter toute cette histoire
objectivement parce que tout ce que je
dis jusqu'au moindre détail et vérité
on a lancé Casablanca Records les
artistes travaillaient avec nous pas
pour nous on formait une famille
on prendrait jamais l'avion pour Houston
et vous avez vraiment dépensé les 3
millions de dollars que Warner vous a
donné comme avance non j'ai dépensé 4
millions
c'était une journée comme les autres
[Musique]
les adore quand il les voit pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à leur faire racheter les
[Musique]
et je savais ce qu'elle pourrait devenir
pour oser aller se frotter à Berry Gordy
faut vraiment être fou c'est la toute
dernière chance de Casablanca c'est
parti on décolle
tout ce que je dis
jusqu'au moindre détail
[Musique]
tout est vrai